E aí
o Olá a todos que estou aqui quem fala é
o Dark sejam muito bem vindos a mais um
vídeo hoje estou aqui com nosso amigo do
que o princesa Suzuki eu não sei porque
eu gostar como é que ele sabe que eu
tenho comida aqui então pessoal o que é
que nós vamos fazer aqui no vídeo de
hoje hoje nós vamos fazer uma
experiência usando tu é e esta vai ter
uma experiência gastronômica porque é
hoje vou tentar fazer as receitas de por
é mais inusitadas de sempre com
ingredientes bizarros Ok É porque eu sou
uma daquelas pessoas que adora purê de
batata aquele por é puro mesmo para
batatas uma gata e eu pensei por que Não
por que não fazer a minha própria
receita de puré mas com outro tipo de
ingredientes em vez de usar o leite EA
água
E aí
e quando na verdade eu nunca fiz um purê
Mas enfim pessoal mas hoje nós vamos
usar muitos ingredientes que vocês já
conhecem eu não sei se consigo imaginar
o sabor disto ó por é de monster Red
Power Rangers Preto Sprite está ficar e
puré de Red Bull aquele por essa
historinha força para vocês fazerem as
nossas atividades físicas não é poderá
ficar bom poderá poderá ficar mal muita
chance só no teste só fazendo aqui nós
vamos ter a certeza pessoal Olha eu vou
lançar um desafio que é uma coisa que já
não falta muito tempo aqui OK Eu vou
estar uma meta de likes 8 1 ou também
nós conseguimos chegar aos 50.000 likes
aqui neste vídeo eu vou fazer uma
receita com esse ingrediente Pera aí eu
vou estar cá
e é isso mesmo pessoal se nós
conseguimos chegar aos 50.000 likes aqui
neste vídeo eu vou fazer um prato com
larvas com larvas vivas não é que larga
que vocês compram aí já feita com Sal e
Pimenta não é larvas vivas eu vou
cozinhar estas larvas Ok então tudo pelo
vocês pessoal chegamos a 50.000 likes
fica aqui o vídeo eu fico aqui a receita
de larvas Ok como que vocês Primeiro
lugar eu acho que vou fazer já o Red
Bull porque eu estou bem curioso como é
que fica uma bebida energética com a por
é a
E aí
o ok pessoal Agora é só esperar é só
esperar até o Red Bull fervente mas não
podemos parar demasiado por correndo tem
muito açúcar e esse açúcar se queimar
pegou a nossa receita portanto Ao estar
de olho parte de olho ó
o OK agora eu não sei o medida exata e
eu não vou arriscar juntar o leite com o
Red Bull porque senão vai ficar a
mistura bem nojenta Então vamos fazer só
assim eu estou aqui a ser o Red Bull e
vamos colocar sou por é por cima até
termos a consistência de purê E aí sim
Acho que fica pronto o nosso por essa
quis fazer muito podre e
e tirar Red Bull bem útil né
G1
E aí
e aqui está o
o Olá pessoal vamos testar esta obra dar
por é de Red Bull e vamos fazer aqui uma
avaliação deverá 10 ok entre todos e se
por acaso até ser bem mas mas vamos ver
eu não ai eu quebro pela pelo chão quero
calma não pode ser ter comida de pessoa
tem cabelo não não é para embaixo 321
Eu também gostei de ter um pouco
o globo sabor mais aproximado que eu
consigo descrever aqui é que sabe a
papinha bebé de pera Sabe aqueles potes
de pera sabem isso mas não é
e levar o som
Olá tudo 19 Red Bull com purê é bom é
bom mas o que é comida pessoa vamos lá
eu vou experimentar aqui esse Trade
Porque eu tô bem curioso porque sempre
que tem um sabor a limão eu não sei se
com limão com batata funciona bem né
em qualquer pessoal poder colocar mais
trai porque ficou bem sou anão
e vamos lá eu acho que está horrível
Cristina muito alemão para lá 321
e este é horrível é quando vocês metem
na boca sem tenho algumas abraço pra
isso ok mas é é com batata eu já é por é
que ele traz velha dessa vou dar um sabe
muito mal tudo já sabem nunca façam por
é com o site e nem correndo luta no
próximo o nosso por é para ficar azul
porque só apertar x fazer o nosso por é
com Power mas o que quero muito
experimentar porque eu sei o que que é É
que tem umas coisas aqui não é mas eu
tenho um filho vídeo tá é que vou ter
que colocar mais por é porque eu
adicionei mais Power do costume a
[Aplausos]
como é que está pessoal o purê de
powerade Ok eu estou com medo da panela
mesmo Olha aí a cor a textura a puré de
parede em 3D zula
E aí
e este é o pior Sabe aquele sabor a
queijo estragado a fiambre estragado
Sabe aquele estragado é isso porque esse
aqui é sofrimento
o sabor azedo sabe a queijo azeite
fiambre azedo Eu dei um nesse praia Ok
mas vamos subir a pontuação da Sprite
Sprite passa a ficar 13 ou 14 e este sim
é o verdadeiro um ok para ele fica um
prato quatro cabo no Red Bull sim são
bem olha lá pessoal vamos para a última
mas será Monster não pode comer isto não
morre paletes série A
Eu já te disse que não é
E ai ai
e isto sabe a vinagre Suzuki sabes que a
vinagre Vinagre é muito mal então bora
lá então a próxima pessoal vamos testar
fazer um puré com Monster este aqui eu
também não sei o que esperar deste deve
ficar muito parecido ao Red Bull mas já
sabem que o sabor da mostra Ok eu já
curti bastante o Red Bull e o
normalmente não sei o costume de ter
mais mostra Então eu não sei se eu vou
gostar deste mas agora vai gostar eu
acho que vou acertar a consistência eu
acho que é mais ou menos essa é assim
este aqui cheira bem
G1
e não esqueçam esqueçam disso
eu acho que vai ter hoje não acho que
você é
o anão
E aí
e bora lá pessoal vamos para o último
teste aqui do puré com Monster já está
bem deixem-me 50.000 likes Neste vídeo
eu vou comer larvas vivas eu vou fazer
uma refeição com armas O que é horrível
é o pior deles todos o pior mesmo
o vômito se era muito bonito este não
consigo comer se o que é que tu achas
acho que eu vou conseguir Monster compor
é em 32 posso 321 vai
G1
e esse é o contrário de todos este o
início é horrível deixa-me comer o
início é o texto é muito bom mas eu não
sei se ela falar comigo pelo arteiro
é só quiser experimentar em casa faça
uma receita de puré com um monte de
coisas permitem é mesmo horrível lá mas
lá para teste é bom eu conseguiria comer
isto se o sul antes do texto Qual é o
antes do After é bem forte do before sem
subir forte e se fosse on come on
é muito bem já como é que tem duas que
isso é o cão que demora mais rápido as
coisas que eu lhe dou Sério vocês
tiveram um cão assim também igual tudo
sem mastigar também tem embaixo eu quero
saber Vamos fazer um minutinho dos cães
que engolem e não mastigam eu não tenho
nota para este Monster mas eu acho que
isto fica é difícil eles fica meio que
no meio que no três Ok não é que no três
por quatro vezes é bom o before tem que
ter que já não é basicamente O Vencedor
deste deste por é é o pêndulo quero Red
Bull tem uma nota 9 porque sabe a
papinha de bebé de pera Então é bom é
ótimo então é isso Red Bull é o campeão
aqui do nosso vídeo só se quiserem teste
em casa ok só não peguei no fogo agora
esse fogão Mas podem estar em casa
experimentem e não como um tudo porque
com certeza que vão ter uma dor de
barriga não é isso que eu quero que
vocês façam então 10 tem só o seu e é
isso Pessoal espero que tenham gostado
aqui deste vídeo já sabem 50.000 likes
Neste vídeo eu vou comer essas larmes só
olhar para
ou será que o frio na barriga mas ovos
já prometi o prometido é devido portanto
50 Milagres aqui neste vídeo eu vou
fazer uma refeição com estas larvas e
quem sabe eu posso ajudar também o
pessoal aqui da casa sem eles saberem
que estão comer larva o que é que vocês
acham é de um vídeo né mas e assim um
hambúrguer do filme Outro Lado tem
ninguém sabe o que é que tá a ideia tá a
ideia só tendo vocês mas é isso Pessoal
espero que tenham gostado aqui neste
vídeo já sabem deixem muito like e
partilhem este vídeo com amigos vosso ou
sem dizer nada só mais um link para ele
lá no WhatsApp mandem só já sabem como é
que funciona nem pessoa obrigado por
estar aqui obrigado por assistirem
fiquem bem e até a próxima
E aí
[Música]